okay I want to have a conversation with
you today in order to maybe focus some
of our economic critiques right now and
make sure that we're not missing the
forest for the trees I think is the
metaphor that that makes the most sense
now if you like this type of segment I
would love to hear from you about it if
this is not the type of analysis that
you find interesting I'm also glad to
hear from you here's my thought we're
increasingly seeing individuals like
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates maligned not
just as bad people personally but as
emblematic of the problem as people
sometimes like to say the problem with
our economy in the United States and
there's a lot that I can find to
criticize about the way that Jeff Bezos
built Amazon and the way that Bill Gates
built Microsoft but I believe that the
focus on these types of tech
entrepreneurs is really not the lowest
hanging fruit that we should be focusing
on in order to fix our economy so I'll
set it up for you and then and then we
can kind of talk through it Bill Gates
created Microsoft Jeff Bezos created
Amazon they've both become obscenely
wealthy personally wealthier than
anybody needs to be their taxes at the
individual level are certainly too low
they should be paying more in taxes they
regularly take advantage of a lack of
regulation which has allowed their
businesses to be more profitable by the
way as an aside I mean Bill Gates at
this point is not even involved with
Microsoft he's just a philanthropist so
it's kind of backwards looking in terms
of Gates but the analysis is still the
same one
so are there criticisms about Bill Gates
and Jeff Bezos in terms of their
businesses of course I mean look at
Amazon Amazon working conditions aren't
good in many warehouses they should be
paying employees more in many cases a
lot of the products they sell are
manufactured with sweatshop labor in
other countries etc etc Bill Gates and
Microsoft took huge advantage of weak
antitrust law in the United States
during the 90s I believe it was you can
search YouTube for some of the
depositions to learn more about that and
there's other criticisms but compared to
what I believe should be the real
targets in order to strengthen and
improve our economy Jeff Bezos and
Bill Gates really just shouldn't be the
focus and they're not the evil doers so
to speak that some make them out to be
Amazon is a huge company that employs a
crazy number of people they've created
so many jobs should working conditions
be improved should some of them be
getting paid more are there problems
with how Amazon uses uses third-party
contractors for deliveries and uses that
to avoid liability of course of course
and I'm right there with you but
consider the good that Amazon has done
during the pandemic people are able to
safely get the things that they need
without leaving their houses people who
live in rural areas and they want to
start a business where in their
immediate area it's tough to get the
products they need to start that
business Amazon can ship the stuff to
them they've allowed countless small
businesses to sell products and be
profitable Microsoft created Windows
which became arguably the catalyst for
the personal computing revolution on
which can we say millions of tens of
millions of jobs are now based in the
information industry so if you want to
argue that regulation should be more
strict on these companies that Microsoft
should have been broken up that Jeff
Bezos doesn't donate enough money to
charity or that he's richer than anyone
should ever be I'm right there with you
but let me suggest that the focus may be
should be elsewhere now first of all a
lot of what people are criticizing about
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates is not really
about Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates
it's about policy so focusing on them is
actually the wrong Avenue while we
continue to elect a lot of the same
people that won't really change anything
but most importantly the focus should be
on the elements of our economy that are
completely unproductive and I would
argue predatory there's criticisms of
Microsoft and Amazon but they also have
done so much good in revolutionising the
world in positive ways look at the bail
industrial complex
what is that industry achieve that is
productive other than making money off
of people in the criminal justice system
what is payday lending achieving other
than skimming obscene interest from
people who can't
their bills what about the financial
instruments including derivatives
derivatives of the ribber derivative
derivatives derivatives of derivatives
etc collateralized loan obligations none
of this stuff really adds to the economy
the people making money from these tools
will say these are legitimate ways to
mitigate risk for large corporations etc
its skimming skimming skimming so that a
small group of people get rich off of
big corporations and rich people hedging
some of their risk debt collection
agencies the entire debt collection
industry even looking at high-frequency
trading within mutual funds so that the
traders and the fund managers earn huge
commissions while they deliver subpar
returns to customers that are investing
their life savings with them in the
financial space there are entire
categories of products that are not
productive for the economy they don't
deliver anything that can be used by
people to make a business or to make
anybody healthier these are entire
swathes of the economy that just enrich
the individuals who come up with and use
these mechanisms to extract money for
themselves so to go back to my main
point there is no question that there
are serious criticisms of our economy
which can be seen through the fact that
people like Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates
have achieved such obscene wealth and
when it comes to antitrust regulation
tack rate tax rates whatever else that's
a real conversation to having I don't
want to belittle it but Amazon's
existence is not where I would focus I
would focus on the entire industries
that exist only to leech and skim from
hardworking people for no benefit to the
broader economy
I believe that's what we should be
paying the most attention to and trying
to fix and I want to hear your thoughts